aller jusqu'aux centres des grandes
villes peut s'avérer difficile quand on
habite en zone rurale pour pallier ces
difficultés l'agglomération rambouillet
territoire a déployé trois navettes de
transport à la demande en 2020 et 3
supplémentaires en janvier 2021
ce qui porte à six le nombre total de
véhicules en circulation un service
nécessaire
ça représente la capacité de se déplacer
avec son simple téléphone devenir des
traits de venir est repris au près de
chez soi juste à côté de chez soi et
d'être emmené sur un des points phares
du territoire les points de ralliement
du territoire c'est une offre qui
n'existaient pas qu'avant il y avait
rien pour utiliser le transport à la
demande d'une plateforme téléphonique
existe mais aussi une application qui
permet dé choisir son art et son arrivée
et son départ
actuellement il fonctionne du mardi au
vendredi de 9h15 à 15 heures 30 et le
samedi de 9h15 à 18h50 à partir du 31
mai il va fonctionner à partir du midi
sur les mêmes horaires que du mardi au
vendredi et le système informatique de
réservation est totalement autonome on
peut réserver jusqu'à un mois al avance
voire une heure à l'avancement et de
manquer aussi protard moins nécessaire
d'avoir un trajet
la première personne qui commande le
circuit déclenché la course et ensuite
il ya un algorithme informatique qui
permettent de faire des regroupements de
personnes fine des demandes arrivent sur
le même trajet après des débuts
difficiles à son lancement le transport
à la demande semble trouver son public
chaque mois la demande augmente de 10%
et le service est entièrement financé
par ile-de-france mobilité